pendant ma on a on m'a repéré après j'ai
passé tous les tous les castings bah sur
les réseaux et puis j'avais sorti des
des petits trucs aussi en indépendant
donc après on a passé le casting
pour toi peut-être pas trop triste de
sortir je vous sens un peu triste quand
même bah c'est sûr qu'on a on va pas
dire qu'on est content d'être sortis
mais après c'est le jeu il fallait un
duo éliminer ça a été nommé on a vécu
trois semaines tellement intense
c'est bon j'ai gagné ouais c'est ça
alors Carla je te dis tout il y a eu
beaucoup de rumeurs qui disent il y a
des gens qui disaient que tu étais
fistonnés qu'est-ce que c'est quoi ces
rumeurs là bah c'est des rumeurs
complètement fausses parce que j'ai pas
été pistonné et oui je pense que ça
parle de Yanis tout ça mais je n'ai pas
du tout été pistonné pour faire la Star
Academy non ouais parce que comme vous
avez vécu la séquence polémique dans
laquelle l'or embrouille Julien enfin la
prof c'est vrai que ça fait énormément
parler moi j'ai dit voilà c'est c'est un
truc voilà c'est vrai que Gilles était
vent debout comme d'habitude pour rien
vous est-ce que vous avez été choqué et
on peut la revoir la séquence vous
l'avez ou pas en régie vous l'avez ou
pas la séquence vous êtes
morts
pas forcément choqué honnêtement dans
notre posture en fait on voit une prof
un élève qui font leur rôle chacun l'un
l'autre et
[Musique]
sur le coup nous on n'a pas on n'a pas
apporté en fait
on n'a pas on n'a pas trouvé l'ordre
trop violente avec Julien elle a été mal
à droite sur certains propos mais après
nous on n'a pas trouvé enfin sur le coup
on sait pas dit c'était quelque chose de
grave en fait c'est après qu'on a vu la
pandémique mais il se passe un truc de
fou non non elle joue son rôle de prof
elle est tellement bienveillante avec
nous on sait qu'elle sera jamais dans la
méchanceté
alors elles ont dit sur le coup mais
après quand vous avez vu la polémique
est-ce que là vous trouvez qu'elle est
allée trop loin
on a besoin de secouer les élèves je
sais que moi parfois quand je me fais
secouer ça me fait du bien après je dis
pas je ne sens plus intelligents je dis
pas que Julien méritait d'être secouer
franchement j'ai pas j'ai pas d'avis à
avoir je suis pas au-dessus de lui pour
parler mais par contre je trouve qu'ils
avaient fait un laver son rôle de prof
il avait son rôle d'élève c'est ça nous
on est là on est dans notre bulle c'est
vrai peut-être qu'on vit différemment de
de ce que vous vous vivez à l'extérieur
quand vous regardez quoi mais
qu'est-ce que tu veux est-ce que vous
êtes vraiment coupé du monde à la star
acade parce qu'il y avait une rumeur sur
un téléphone portable qui circulait dans
le château qu'on vous aura plu
ah non allez prime c'est un truc de fou
de voir des gens qui parlent on voit nos
proches dans le public on voit des gens
ça nous fait bizarre mais c'est vraiment
le téléphone une minute une minute ça
nous rend malheureuse que vous voyez à
la télé c'est vraiment c'est vrai
alors vous avez eu le droit à un tableau
de danse samedi alors que vous étiez
nommé trouvez pas ça juste on va le
revoir d'ailleurs merci c'est super dur
quoi ouais
mon gars super j'ai dû
faire le plus souvent c'est quand je
sens que
de suivre ce café
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en même temps c'est pas c'est pas facile
trois personnes savent le faire
en plus c'est en vrai c'est
c'est le contexte aussi je pense d'être
nommé et de se dire je vais devoir
assurer sur un truc qui est pop qui est
léger je vais devoir attirer les gens je
vais devoir avoir mon souffle et ne pas
gueuler moi je sais que j'ai gueulé
non justement en rapport à cette
séquence j'ai vu que sur internet ça
avait été compliqué pour vous les gens
ont été très méchants suite à cette
séquence comment est-ce que vous l'avez
vécu bah c'est sûr que les commentaires
enfin moi je sais que je regarde pas
tout on n'a pas tout regardé ce qui
s'était passé sur Twitter bien sûr qu'on
passe à côté
négatifs il y en a qu'on prend en compte
mais après enfin moi je sais que je me
confirme vraiment surprise il y a des
choses qui sont vraies moi
qu'on a fait vocalement un truc qui
était pas ouf et alors en fait on est
des élèves et je suis fier de nous bravo
bien sûr
pour ce prime les téléspectateurs ont
jugé que la meilleure prestation était
celle d'anisha avec Slimane elle a
tellement bien chanté qui lui a même
annoncé une surprise à la fin à Slimane
je crois qu'il doit faire son bonnet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je voulais juste dire que ben moi je
suis en tournée en ce moment
et que j'invitais à venir chanter avec
moi
alors tu vas venir pendant mon passage
solo donc il va falloir que tu apprennes
des milliers de je t'aime ça te fait du
travail en plus je suis désolé
je crois que c'est à la dérange pas
merci pour ce cadeau généreux jusqu'au
bout
[Applaudissements]
c'est fort
il y a beaucoup plus de filles au
château que de garçons et comme par
hasard dans les dominos il y avait donc
deux duoschis est-ce que c'est fait
exprès pour que là il est juste un
nombre
égalise
on est des élèves on apprend alors il y
en a un qui kiff pas du tout la Star Ac
et c'est Eddy Mitchell vous connaissez
Eddy Mitchell
[Musique]
[Rires]
et moi je kiffe les gars quand vous aime
ou pas voilà moi j'adore les mecs qui
ouvrent leur gueule et c'est un dernier
un des derniers mecs qui disent qu'il
pense moi j'adore voilà c'est comme
Michel Sardou Eddy Mitchell voilà et dit
Michel il a dit qu'il était pas grand
fan de l'émission après voilà vous en
foutez vous ferez votre carrière mais
moi j'aime le gars les gars qui disent
des trucs je suis désolé c'est pas comme
Gilles Verdez qui suit le mouvement à
chaque fois il y a des mecs et pour les
poulets il y a des gars qui bloquent une
autoroute il est pour une autoroute
sur le plateau de la nouvelle version de
la Star Academy sur TF1 Eddy Mitchell je
pense pas non
est-ce que vous auriez envie d'y aller
bah non pas vraiment
[Musique]
que tout ça et les otarie c'est un peu
des chiens savants quoi donc autant dire
que si on proposait à Eddy Mitchell de
devenir coach juré dans un télé-crochet
type The Voice Star Academy non ouais
non vraiment vous en avez vraiment rien
à cirer Eddy Mitchell je crois que c'est
clair pour tout le monde
jamais vraiment
voilà ça va ça va ça va franchement ça
va ça va souvent aussi un savon
que ceux qui défendent la star qui
disent quoi rien merci
on va voir des amis comme vous
maintenant
faire une grande carrière ah bah oui
parce que c'est ce qu'on veut
je danse je chante voilà
23 ans
moi pareil moi aussi j'ai travaillé
aussi un peu avant et est-ce que vous
avez des propositions de maison de
disques ou pas encore pas pour le moment
parce que c'est très tôt on est sorti à
deux jours donc pour le moment des
messages un petit peu mais c'est pas
directement les messages mais non pour
le moment ça sera plus tard
vraiment et même dans la vie je trouve
qu'elle parle bien non non on s'en fout
non franchement je voulais vous dire
vous êtes incroyable merci vous avez
deux personnalités incroyables vous
chantez bien vous dansez bien vous allez
réussir mais tous ceux qui sortent tu
trouves qu'ils sont incroyables
le casting est très très fort